was it always your choice to have the
Red Skull protecting the stolen stone
and how did he come to know all the
rules well he first of all he had a very
mystical ending at the end of Captain
America First Avenger he so you know
he's been on a journey since then he's a
he's a wraith now you know he is a slave
to the stones and and he is no longer
the same person he's transcendent and
you know he's a ghost
so I think he was always the that
character we may have played around with
once or twice it not being him but we
always thought we need someone that the
audience is going to trust that when he
explains the rules of how you obtain the
stone that they will believe the
character and we thought I think his
marks McFeely fought really hard to have
him back in the film artist and clearly
wrote First Avenger so they were close
to that character did Hugo Weaving ever
come close to reprising the role he may
have kind of he was asked I understand
what was the process of figuring out
where the soul stone would be
considering the hype surrounding it but
we knew that we needed to do something
special with that stone but we knew that
we also needed it to have an emotional
connection to the plot and to Thanos as
a character and it took us I think those
the last stone that we figured out where
it was because that was the hardest
story to come up with and it was really
you know when at a point where we
decided that the movie was hispanos his
movie we needed the the you know the
lowest moment of the film to belong to
him
and so that's when we started to develop
the soulstone story was you know how
could we how could we create pain how
could we dimensionalize him so that he
went on a journey in the film because if
he was just this mindless and Dylan it
was going to become a two-dimensional
story the soulstone obviously is the
ability to you know manipulate your soul
the essence of who you are the one key
moment where where it gets used is when
dr. strange if you've noticed this but
he turns into multiple strangers and
then Thanos he uses the soul stone to
eradicate all the fake strangers and
momentarily shove strange out of his own
body strange has to pull himself back in
so of course when when anis goes to the
soul stone itself who to speak to is his
dead daughter obviously has the ability
to resurrect and conjure you know the
spiritual representation of people are
dead